said well it started with a relationship
that took a turn
and ended with alleged revenge porn one
man is now facing felony charges after
what he posted on social media
it is a story the i-team first broke
earlier today in the i-team's vanessa
murphy
live outside of the clark county
detention center with more vanessa
well if you post sexually explicit
images of someone without their
permission
it's a crime in nevada now one man is in
jail here facing a felony
relationship it doesn't mean she
contends to keep going and humiliating
her putting
what was the private video
pictures between the two of you and
blasting on twitter michael gatos is
accused of revenge porn
posting sexually explicit images of a
woman without her permission
after their relationship ended the
49-year-old man appeared in las vegas
justice court monday
he faces a felony charge for unlawful
dissemination of an intimate image of
another person
that is an extremely harmful thing to
have happen to you
danielle staple is the executive
director of the rape crisis center
it's a violation of trust it's a
violation of
our our faith in in somebody that we are
in a relationship of any sort with
gatosk was arrested on a warrant on
april first according to court records
documents obtained by the i-team reveal
the alleged crime dates back to november
and the alleged victim came forward the
following month
police say she told them she and gatosk
took consensual nude photos and made a
sexually explicit video
in may she asked him to delete the video
and believed that
he did but metro police say they
obtained a
series of text messages from november
gato sent to the alleged victim and her
partner
taunting the other man and threatening
the woman
quote pics and videos released remember
you did this
end quote detectives say gatos posted
nude photos and sexually explicit video
on twitter and the images were up for
two hours before being removed
i grew up in a different time and uh
if i let someone take pictures of me
naked they'll shame on me
we can't really be going around blaming
the victim for agreeing to
send nude pictures to someone with whom
she's in a consensual
relationship
and the head of the rape crisis center
who you heard from there says that is
part of the problem
victim blaming now as for gatos the
judge said he could be released on his
own recognizance but she said she didn't
really want to and that she was just
following a supreme court decision
she pointed out he has no criminal
history and he would
be considered low risk according to jail
records though he
has not yet been released reporting live
from downtown las vegas vanessa murphy 8
news now